παράλσαν τα πάντα και οι καιονομες και δεν δεν υπήρχε τίποτε δεν μπορούσε να λειτουργήσει
τε εροδρόμοι ότι τίποτα εμείς είχαμε σκεφτεί οραία πώς μπορούμε με ασφάλεια τώρα που έχουμε
την πιθανότετα εμβολιασμού να αρχίσει να ανίγει το πράκαι μέσα σε τρεις μήνες από το
νομίζοτοα αναπρίλις μέχρι τον ιούνιο σχεδιάσαμε εφαρμόσαμε το ψηφιακό πιστοποιτικό χόβι τ το οποίο επέτρεψε
στις κοινωνίες και στις οικονομίες να ξαναρχίσουν τα λειτουργού αυτό αμέσως μέσα να σκεφτούμε ακοινήθηκαμε
τόσο γρήγορα σε μια κρίση γιατί να μην μπορούμε να ψηφιοποιήσουμε τα θέματα εγείας ώστε
ο ευρωπαίος πολί της να επηγαίνει διακοπές στην ισπανία και να έχει στο κινητών του
όλον το ιστορικό το αυτό έχει προχωρήσει γι αυτό θεωρώ ότι είμαστε μπολύ πιο προετοιμασμένοι
δι ότι έχουν ν αλλάξει ρηστικά ποακαδιβάσεις έχουν μπει βάσεις και προχωρούν και ηλοποιούνται ι
σχέσας με την οικογένεια ίσα στα μακριά πέντε χρόνια ερχός να σταν συχνά στηνκύπρο ίσως
και ερδυθούν κάποιες στιγμέσ σε μερικές εβδομάδες που φεύκεται από επίτροπος σκαι επιστρέφεται θααναζητήσετε κάποιες
στιγμές σις αλκά που χάσατε αυτά τα χρόνια στην κύπρον είνιοσύζιγοσμού τα δύο μου παιδιάζουν
εξωτερικό σίγουρα όταν πήγα ανέλαβα ω σεπίτροπος διαφορετικά περιμέναμε τα πράγματα διοτι ήρχθε επανδιμία και
ήταν αδύνατων ι οποιο δήποτε να ταξιδεύσει πιστεύω ότι επιστρέφοντας την κύπρο σίγουρα θα έχω
ίσως κάποιον περισσότερο χρόνο τουλαχιστον αριθμίζω το πρόγραμμα μου